[Music]
this fate completes the depopulation of
heaven of that unthinking mingling of
individuality in essence a mingling
whereby the action of essence appears as
inconsequent arbitrary unworthy of
itself for individuality that is only
superficially attached to essence is
unessential
the expulsion of such shadowy
insubstantial picture thoughts which was
demanded by the philosophers of
antiquity thus already begins in greek
tragedy in general through the fact that
the division of the substance is
controlled by the notion and
consequently individuality is essential
and the determinations are absolute
characters
the self-consciousness that is
represented in tragedy knows and
acknowledges therefore only one supreme
power
and this zeus only as the power of the
state or of the hearth and in the
antithesis belonging to knowing of
nowhere known
only as the father of the particular
that is taking shape in the knowing and
also as the zeus of the oath and of the
furies the zeus of the universal of the
inner being dwelling
in concealment
the further moments issuing from the
notion
and dispersed throughout the pictorial
representation moments which the chorus
allows to hold sway one after the other
are on the other hand not the pathos of
the hero they sink to the level of
passions in the hero to the level of
contingent insubstantial moments which
though praised by the impersonal chorus
are not capable of constituting the
character of the heroes nor of being
expressed and honored as their essential
nature
paragraph 741 begins with this reference
to fate which was discussed in the
previous paragraph so we probably
want to go back and just look at that
for a moment we have this unmoved unity
of faith peaceful existence
consequent inactivity lack of vitality
and equal honor and consequent
indifferent unreality which he then
talks about as being this unitary
being of zeus and i pointed out in the
last paragraph commentary that when we
see zeus here don't think a character
don't think just the first among equals
in the greek pantheon think something
like a universal principle think about
the
totality of the pantheon rather than
just one
god who happens to have gotten up on top
and gets to tell the others what to do
so this fate
shiks all
destiny we could call it other things as
well
there's a kind of sense of determinism
here but even more than that to focus
solely on determinism would be
a bit misleading what we see is
something like
a
loss an evacuation of the full
meaning of things and we saw that again
in the previous paragraph this is
revealing to us
what is going on in the development of
tragedy and here hegel uses a very
interesting word he tells us
that
something is being completed another way
of talking about that would be
fulfilled brought to its telos full end
it right
uh sort of like the greek to lao tau in
to be brought to its end this is the end
of tragedy all this other stuff that
we've been doing
in a way is just leading us to that
so the word that he uses
that miller translates as depopulation
is actually a richer word
and
right so you see that word folk in there
that has come up a number of times in
this entire section and actually at a
number of places in the phenomenology
folk
is a people it is not the same thing
necessarily as
nation which is sometimes just you know
the translation of the german cognate
not your own right or knocks it all
and a folk
has a
a
culture a
set of mythoid stories right it has its
own
ways of articulating
itself it is different than other [ __ ]
right
although it's not completely different
from them sometimes it exists in
relations of borrowing as you know
happened throughout the greco-roman
world where they took other people's
gods and brought them into the pantheon
the romans and greeks drew upon each
other quite a bit and there's all sorts
of others involved in the story as well
i don't want to get bogged down in
historical details here
so what is
and
depopulation
okay well that's one way to carry out
a and focus to just get rid of everybody
all the people
that are there
but
is it really a folk up in heaven a
people
isn't it more like you know the gods
themselves who are kind of on top of the
the pile we might say you know the uh
top of the food chain
dialectically speaking well yes
so
what are we talking about here i mean we
could use it just in the trivial sense
it just means evacuation make everybody
get out of heaven so that there's just
room for one
main thing this fate or zeus or however
we're going to think about it you know a
single principle
but it could also mean a reduction of
the connection between the
human beings the fuch
the folk rather the [ __ ] right the
peoples who are
engaging in tragedy to better understand
their own gods this brings us back to
the topic of
religion and so a depopulation of heaven
would mean
a disconnect
between these
whatever we're going to call them we
soon have a name for them actually a
category for them
in hegel's own workings
we're looking at the
the beginning of
secularity of
a lessening of devotion of all these
things that we've been talking about
before
what is going on in heaven
so the very next line tells us
that
unthinking one dankiness right
mingling
uh
their mission mixing up together
of individuality and essence veisin and
here he says something interesting a
mingling whereby the action in this case
not handling but taught
of essence appears as
inconsequent
arbitrary
unworthy of itself
why
because individuality that is doing the
action right
individuality that's doing the action on
the part of the essence
that is only superficially attached to
essence
is unessential now is is
is that just a tautology on hegel's part
well if it's not essential then it's
inessential
yes you could read it that way but you
could also read it as individuality has
been you could say
impersonating taking on the position of
the the essence the essential and so
as a stand-in if it's not really
connected with that that and what is the
essence here well we're gonna get to
that it's not just an individual thing
and like he says
inconsequent arbitrary unworthy of
itself
what the individuals are doing
and the drama is in a certain sense
lacking
it is
arbitrary right
so
what do we have in heaven
this is where we get to something very
important he says
the expulsion right the depopulation
expulsion of what now here miller adds
an extra word that it isn't really
necessary here but let's read it anyway
such shadowy
insubstantial picture thoughts
so what are what are these
vase and lozen insubstantial and you
want to call them shadowy that's that's
fine i think you know it's a little bit
of a
extra thing there that's not in the
german text but yeah that's all right
four stelling picture thoughts
representations right and we're gonna
see
that there's gonna be a contrast drawn
already the contrast that runs
throughout all of hagel's works between
the four stellang and the griff the
concept the notion different modes not
only of knowing something
but of presenting something to to us
to the
people at that stage that shape of
consciousness that we're talking about
ancient greece and its tragedies or we
could be extending this perhaps to other
cultures as well
so in substantial picture thoughts
that's what we've got to work with and
we should pause for a moment and think
about
when we encounter
greek tragedy
how does it work
i mean we are very hyper conscious about
this genre right we may teach it in a
literature class and then we we don't
get it on stage as a production
instead we get it as a
essentially a play written in a book
we just get dialogue and stage direction
and we have to use our imagination
those are all
representations they can't we can go
beyond that as we're reading it we can
be reading you know eschalis agamemnon
and you know have a sense of dread of
what's going on and we're not like
picturing agamemnon in our head in the
bathtub we're conceptualizing what what
is actually happening there which is not
just somebody dying being hacked while
he's you know bound up within his robes
but rather a fundamental betrayal a
concept here a
horror that is taking place that has
been hinted at and depicted throughout
the the way in which the play is talked
about so that's one way we encounter
these plays and you know that was also
possible back in the ancient world
people would read homer people would
read echelos
but they'd also see it put on
they would see the spectacle of the play
and for a little while they could be
invested
in it
leaving part of themselves behind so
that they actually are the audience
and even participating as sort of
something like the
chorus feeling things
right
what they're getting though
is foreshadowing
somebody is up there and there's all
kinds right we have the if there's any
sort of scenery on the stage we have the
masks that the actor is wearing which
hegel will be talking about shortly and
paragraphs yet to come there is the
workings of the body that are being used
to depict things to depict actions to
depict attitudes to depict passions
there is the actual speech that is being
given forth by the characters there is
the staging all of that is foreshadowing
right so that's what's in this this
heaven
as he's calling it and now notice what
he says here this is really
interesting
the this expulsion which was demanded
by who
philosophers of antiquity
well who is he talking about there well
aristotle will talk about tragedy
so by the time that that you know
aristotle is on the scene tragedy is
already a very well established art he's
not the one who's demanding it
so we have to go a little further back
plato is pretty hostile to tragedy
uh as we all know
and
maybe he inherited that from from
socrates maybe that was the fact that he
was a poet himself and abandoned it
oh you know there's all sorts of
speculations possible about that
he certainly does want something that is
the one
right the form of the good or the
beautiful what if we go further back
well we have
some
uh thinkers who are depopulating the
heavens by you could say secularizing
them and saying that stuff that you're
talking about up there it's just rocks
man or just you know cosmic forces it's
not god's doing things
and then we have others who are much
more interested in metaphysical
principles that govern everything
or even
just are what they are think about
permanentes right so we have this
this rejection
of the four stellen by
ancient philosophers
and he says that this was demanded by
the philosopher's antiquity thus already
begins in greek tragedy in general
through the fact what fact
that the division of the substance is
controlled by the notion beheshed right
uh rules over literally so the notion
the begriff
is what
divides the substance what is the
substance all of the stuff that's going
into the tragedy all of the
forces powers laws uh
different dialectical transformations
like that of nowhere and and known as
we're going to get to
in just a moment now division of
substance ain't thailand
is this just like saying okay
this is over here this is over here this
is over here cut cut cut cut cut
not exactly and thailand could also be
understood as something more deliberate
like a signing right so this this
division of the substance of all the
things that go into the drama
is happening in some sort of
rational way
so
now notice consequently
individuality
is essential individuality
so
when the notion is governing we're no
longer dealing with the heaven
for stellan where individuality and
essence were just kind of mingled
together here's a little bit of
individuality here's some essence throw
them into the pot stir it around
hopefully something good comes out no in
this case
individuality
is in fact essential
we have to ask though well which
individuality and here's where we're
going to get
self-consciousness
as something
like a character but before that he says
um right before that he says the
determinations are absolute
characters
what does it mean to be an absolute
character
i mean we we could say that sometimes in
a comedic way oh man that guy's an
absolute character meaning like wow look
at that screw up or look at how funny he
is or we don't usually say it in tragic
senses do we
somebody's being a character means
they're putting on a persona and they're
making us laugh at something
that's not what hagel means
so
when we look at tragedies
here's here's one way of thinking about
it we encounter
characters who then
as we say take on a life of their own
right hamlet
isn't just hamlet in the play and he's
not just the whether there was a
historical hamlet or not we're not
worried about that
it becomes a stand-in for for what for
our own
indecisiveness about what we ought to do
in the face of
horror and just the injustice when we're
called upon by the victims of injustice
well that's one reading right hamlet
could also be a guy who's caught in a
screwed up family dynamic and doesn't
know which way to turn can't figure out
who the good guys are and who the bad
guys are or if there are any good guys
at all
or and we can go on with other
interpretations each of those could be
what hegel is calling an absolute
character here how do we interpret
oedipus how do we interpret crayon how
do we interpret antigone
how do we interpret any of these people
how do we interpret ajax
in the ajax right
or
medea as a prime example i mean i think
i've pointed this out in the past i
think medea as a play
might pose some problems for hegel's
discussion of tragedy here but that's
that's a separate topic right
so he says the
self-consciousness that is represented
in tragedy
knows
and acknowledges now this is interesting
we've been talking about knowledge a lot
and that's usually been framed in terms
of vissen
right
now it's canon
canon and anaer canon canon is knowing
as well but it's knowing we often say
when we're teaching people about german
as opposed to vissen you know
you know advice
it can
these are different modes of knowing
different ways of knowing you know
getting to know somebody
is canon right you you get to know them
over time and then you can recognize
them through that on-air cannon
by the way you know anakin is something
that is driving the entire dialectic of
the entire phenomenology
arguably i would argue that to say that
it's one of the most important
concepts
that emerges you know first in
self-consciousness and we're always
trying to make sense of it so the
individual the self-consciousness knows
and acknowledges but they know and
acknowledge
as
represented not as
the notion the grief
and what do they know only one supreme
power
what is this one supreme power this zeus
right this zeus and it's known as
only as the power of the state
or the hearth
and in the antithesis belonging to
knower
knowing of nowhere and known
only as the father of the particular
that is taking shape and the knowing
and also
as the zeus of the oath and the furies
the zeus of the universal of the inner
being dwelling in concealment so these
are all
ways in which zeus is known by the
individual self-consciousness who is
somebody in the play but also
one of us
if we're watching it if we're reading it
if we're thinking about it if we're
grasping it in this way so the notion
is still here behind the scenes
what we really have here is still
forest along representation being
represented to a representative
you might say who is the individual
self-consciousness the individual
self-consciousness of who well
here we get to the other thing the
further moments
and it's rare that hegel actually uh
includes these further moments that are
you know you might say
part of what else is going on but he's
talking about totality and it's pretty
important that he talks about the
further moments in this case because
otherwise what the hell is the hero
doing right so we do have a hero
involved here
and harry says something really
interesting as well i mean this is this
paragraph is so rich
in what's going on
the further moments
issuing from the notion so coming from
the griff the great you know dividing up
the substance
and dispersed throughout the pictorial
representation throughout the four
shelling the overall foreshadowing of
the drama
moments which the chorus
allows to hold sway one after the other
so here we have a chorus
involved here a reference to them
we're going to come back to that in a
moment
what are these
further moments
r on the other hand
not the pathos
of the hero
they sink to the level of passions
in the hero
okay so let's clarify that a little bit
the english
connects these up
a little bit better than the german does
interestingly enough pathos in german is
pathos
and passions
leidenshaft
things that we suffer
right which goes back to the you know
original sense of passion
now here's where it gets really tricky
in ancient greek
we have pathos
and pathos means what it just means
passion or emotion
apothose technically speaking
is something that we suffer something
that we undergo
and so prime examples of the pathe given
by aristotle uh particularly in in the
rhetoric are anger it's opposite
calmness proudest right not understood
as the virtue of that fear and
confidence
um hatred and love and we can go on and
on down the line aristotle covers quite
a few of those in the rhetoric that's
not the comprehensive list of the
passions because he also talks about
pothos grief
in other places like you know nick
mccann ethics book nine and eudaimian
ethics as well right
joy is one of the emotions these are
things that we feel right
so then
going back to this maybe we don't have a
nice distinction that would be reflected
in the german in in the ancient greek
well we can talk about other
emotion words pathemata or things like
that but this is this is not really
what hegel is referencing the idea of
pothos here
is an emotional
state and an experience
that
is in some respect universal
so
when we're
watching
oedipus rex and we come to the moment of
horror
you are
the one who has killed your father
and who has
not only had sex with your mother but
generated four children with her who are
your children and also your brothers and
sisters and oedipus is struck by this
that's supposed to be pathos
right you can even say that you know
teresius is dread to reveal this being
compelled by uh oedipus is also a kind
of pathos the pathos that
um antigone is displaying the pathos
that crayon is displaying here we're
just sticking to that one sequence of
plays right
but we could extend this into others
is
coming back to the medea is there a
pathos
in the medea specific to madea that
somebody like hegel doesn't doesn't
actually pick up on i would say yes
she was one of the most discussed
figures in antiquity when we come to
talking about the emotions by the way
separate topic so individual emotions
that we can relate to you know like when
we're watching a sitcom and you know i
used to actually have to like leave the
room sometimes when embarrassing things
would happen because i would feel
embarrassed for these fictional
characters on tv some of you probably
had the same experience as well
sometimes i would actually like flip
past pages in a book where something
like that was happening too because i
didn't want to
feel their their shame and embarrassment
but it's not necessarily pothos so the
in the firm there are moments if we
don't have a hero who has pathos
then it descends merely to passions to
emotions and what's the problem with
that
well he says to the level of contingent
in substantial moments
right and this is what we had earlier in
talking about the the heaven that's this
depopulated right in substantial picture
thoughts picture thoughts can be
representations in the sense of
images words they can also be passions
live and shoften so
now let's come back to the chorus
so we said that the chorus allows to
hold sway one after the other how by
getting its busy body little noses in
there and talking about what's going on
that's what the chorus does in the play
right and the chorus can be played by
you know the council of old men it can
be a crowd it can be whoever you got
right but they're they're they're
talking they're engaging in things
they're telling us how to interpret the
actions of the hero and all these other
things that are part of the scene
so
we have these insubstantial moments
though praised by the impersonal
chorus
but they're not capable of constituting
the character
of the heroes
okay so we would need pathos not just
pathe
or
passions or lyden shoften to be a
genuine character
not just a type but a character in the
sense of something essential so he says
they cannot be
expressed and honored as their essential
nature so we have kind of an impasse
here right
and this is not a paragraph in which a
resolution happens instead the notion
has kind of receded and all we're left
with
are all of these representations and the
question how are they connected with
each other and what do we do with them
the chorus
and for us the spectators
we're not going to actually be able to
do
what would be demanded by the concept at
this point
you